il faut que l'argent retourne vous
voulez venir
alors cet argent il fait alors et moi
nous l'avons gagné dans un métier précis
qui est celui de la mode et un autre
sens aussi comme au mien l'argent doit
retourner là
Pierre Berger bonsoir bonsoir il y a une
chose qui est assez fascinante
finalement dans votre destin c'est que
après guerre vous vouliez être citoyen
du monde vous étiez branché avec Gary
Davis et puis finalement aujourd'hui
vous êtes devenus un citoyen du monde
parce que avec les activités de
Saint-Laurent dans le monde entier et le
fait que vous fassiez partie de la
jet-set est-ce que on dit toujours qu'on
passe sa vie à réaliser ses rêves de
jeunesse est-ce que vous n'êtes pas
devenu un citoyen du monde d'une autre
manière vous savez d'abord à l'époque on
n'était pas branché et je suis pas tout
à fait sûr de faire partie de la Jet Set
quand elle était assez citoyen du monde
si c'est les vrais que il suffit de
voyager autour de la terre et de faire
ce voyage souvent alors là oui je suis
un citoyen du monde ça me semble pas
suffisant vous êtes toujours associé à
55 ans parce que c'est un mythe si vous
voulez pour pour beaucoup de jeunes
entrepreneurs dont j'ai fait partie une
époque c'était de dire
on y viendra tout à l'heure je pense que
vous n'êtes pas seulement un commercial
mais c'était 50% pour le commercial 50%
pour le créateur et c'était un peu le
couple moderne alors est-ce que la vie
des affaires vous a permis de conserver
cette
équité dans votre action mariage chez
Yves Saint Laurent entre Yves Saint
Laurent et moi les quitter était
maintenu
pour autant nous avons dû récemment
puisque nous nous sommes portés et nous
avons acquis nous sommes portés
acquéreur et nous avons acquis les
parfums cosmétiques Yves Saint Laurent
qui qui nous appartenaient pas nous
avons dû pour cela faire appel à des
partenaires et nous avons appelé et qui
est venu avec nous car le Benedetti
voilà et donc évidemment ça a modifié un
petit peu l'actionnariat du
Saint-Laurent est-ce qu'il y a pas chez
vous finalement pendant de longues
années vous avez été considéré comme le
commercial d'Yves Saint Laurent et puis
est-ce qu'il y a pas un désir de montrer
que vous êtes autre chose quand on lit
votre curriculum vitalité enfin j'ai
reçu enfin je me suis procuré plutôt
deux que vous concernant le premier il y
a cinq lignes sur votre aventure avec
Yves Saint Laurent qui racontait comme
ça en 5 lignes comme une chose allant de
soi dans le deuxième vous faites passer
il y a marqué culture et mode et vous
faites passer culture avant mode vous
êtes occupé de théâtre avec la télé avec
Edouard 7 d'édition avec Renaud Barrau
et les livres que vous avez publiés
c'est je sais pas proche mais est-ce que
il y a pas une frustration qui se
traduit par un désir d'être connu vous
aussi comme quelqu'un peut-être pas
obligatoirement un artiste mais
quelqu'un qui est très concerné par les
choses de l'art et vous allez tiré
Ardisson c'est vous qui m'avez demandé
de venir merci beaucoup si j'étais
soustrait je voudrais demander à venir
je n'ai pas fait donc je suis pas tout à
fait frustré je suis très content d'être
où je suis et j'occupe la place que je
cure
tout d'un coup des gens s'intéressent à
moi je sais pas vraiment pourquoi je
sais pourquoi parce qu'il y a 10 ans je
faisais un journal underground et chaque
fois qu'on avait des problèmes on allait
vous voir pour vous nous aidiez donc je
pense que vous avez tendance à aider les
artistes d'une façon générale et c'est
plutôt louable pas seulement les
artistes je crois qu'il y a des projets
intéressants et que dans la vie ce qu'il
y a de plus intéressant c'est de
partager non c'est ce qui est le plus
beau je me méfie des des gens qui ont
les mains fermés qui doutent de tout
susceptiques et qui mettent l'autre en
doute moi je fais confiance il y a
beaucoup de dragons qui ont couru ces
dernières années sur la santé de Yves
Saint Laurent ils faisaient beaucoup de
choses
qu'il abusé de certaines substances qui
étaient malades etc est-ce que vous
pouvez nous répondre franchement oui
bien sûr pourquoi ne pas répondre
franchement allons-y et puis écoutez il
faut pas qu'on fonde ceci et cela ça
leur rend est un créateur
il est un homme fragile
il crée quatre fois par an avec le
bonheur et le succès qu'on sait et ça
dure depuis 30 ans alors moi j'en
connais qui ont abandonné beaucoup plus
de plumes que ça non et à force de mal
se porter ça il est comme disait Cocteau
et là une solide mauvaise santé
je sais pas si c'est vrai sans avoir 150
millions de dollars pourquoi pourquoi
amasser tout cet argent pour qui vous
avez pas d'enfants vous avez pas de ce
qu'elle a en faire tout ce pognon mais
dites-moi d'abord j'ai pas amassé 150
millions de dollars c'est c'est faux
déjà je sais pas moi vous savez j'ai pas
beaucoup de sous moi alors déjà c'est
faux parce que c'est pas 150 millions de
dollars assurance donc vous avez pas
dans un coffre
peser vous valez oui l'argent c'est sur
des actions cette société qui s'appelle
Yves Saint Laurent qui te sont qui
étaient évalués qui vont rentrer en
bourse et qui sera évalué un prix je
connais pas de succès sans argent faire
quoi de cet argent d'abord faudrait-il
que je vends des titres des actions pour
avoir de l'argent un jour on est tous
réduits au même point je dirais un jour
vous serez on sera tous on aura tous 70
ans
parce que je trouve que il faut que
l'argent retourne il est venu
alors cet argent il fait un Laurent et
moi nous l'avons gagné dans un métier
précis qui est celui de la mode et un
autre sens aussi comme au mien l'argent
doit retourner là alors il faut faire
une fondation
pour apprendre et pour montrer ce que
c'est que ce métier ce que c'est que la
mode et puis il faut y ajouter beaucoup
d'autres choses
des salles d'exposition et puis et puis
disons faire un petit peu ce que les
musées sont incapables de faire il y
avait une voilà de Saint-Laurent un
moment qui disait pour ceux qui vivent
avec talent donc vous essayez de vivre
avec talent
oui écoutez poursuivre votre question
j'essaierai de mourir avec talent
c'est des coûts pour avoir de la presse
vous pensez vraiment bien marché en
chinois
dans les journaux quoi
c'est par ce que j'aime bien faire les
choses les premiers voilà alors va y
venir justement vous êtes très fier
d'avoir
reçu chez Saint-Laurent raïsset
Gorbatchev oui je suis très fier aussi
d'avoir été de dîner chez elle
vous défendez SOS Racisme et de l'autre
côté vous défendre enfin vous défendez
pas mais vous fréquentez et la presse
sans fait l'écho allègrement la femme
d'un type qui est quand même interdit
aux Juifs de sortir du RSS ce qui
maintient des gens dans les camps de
concentration finalement c'est trahisha
Gorbachev c'est la femme d'un dictateur
vous savez parfaitement ou alors puisque
parlons de glabe aujourd'hui
vous ne m'auriez pas lu ce que je ne
peux pas croire oui je vous dis alors
puisque vous me lisez régulièrement vous
savez parfaitement que je ne pense pas
ce que vous dites de Monsieur corbatchev
et vous consommez sa femme vous savez
parfaitement que au moment où nous
parlons je soutiens autant que possible
la politique de corbatchev vous pensez
qu'il dit la vérité écoutez moi je pense
que monsieur sakaro fait libre et je
pense que le Riya fait retourner en
Russie il y a 15 jours je constate comme
vous comme moi que ce qui était
impossible il y a un an deux ans encore
plus autrefois devient possible
aujourd'hui alors je pense ce que je
vous ai dit tout à l'heure pour les
jeunes gens dont vous étiez et qui
veniez me demander de l'aide sur des
projets je vous la donnais parce que je
vous faisais confiance absolument alors
monsieur campbatchev n'a pas demandé
d'aide mais moi je lui fais confiance et
je préfère faire confiance à Monsieur
Corbas
je n'aime pas ou que ce soit de
quelqu'un maniaque ce soit les
procédures je fais confiance
absolument et pour être sûr de ne rien
rater de innarditude abonnez-vous et
mettez un pouce bleu